today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach if you think you
could do something with your life that
something could be great block today's
guests managed to plant the seeds of an
entrepreneurial business mastermind all
the while becoming a champion in the
world of cage fighting he's no longer
fighting but he's got so many things
going on in the business world that his
career just continues to climb
today's guest is mr. Urijah Faber but
now I've never seen anybody I mean
that's really just making the most out
of things Rob when I was in the lobby
what not I was getting I tried a napkin
I was trying to a couple there so you
really get in there what is because you
took over you just took an Aquafina wrap
the the wrapper off of a bottle and then
used it because it's thin enough to
floss your teeth with absolutely I love
that yeah it's a fact it's a genetic
thing I think my dad I remember driving
around my dad's old beat-up truck he
always had toothpicks or yeah a little
crappy toothbrush he's keeping a centre
console and he was constantly digging
honesty and said we must have genetic
think on genetic teeth gaps that store
food it might have been a survival
tactic back in the day yeah yeah useless
now right yeah pretty much just to spend
money on dental floss do you keep floss
around do you argue that you do I do
usually or I'll grab if I'm in a
restaurant I'll get like a couple you
know toothpicks yeah for the day my
girls always making fun of me she's like
I've never seen so many floss or teeth
I've got she makes one for a couple of
things one is being a mouth breather
mm-hmm and I'm like I was in 44
professional fights I've been punched in
the nose I can breathe it all yeah okay
give it and lucky I'm not more damage
than I already am like a machine yeah
exactly
and and then the dental-floss thing but
I just can't handle having a bunch of
crap stuck in my teeth
yeah now is it because you worry that
other people's seed or it's just a thing
thanks kids yeah just gets on my nerves
I don't I don't really care right do you
feel like it's an unorganized thing like
I'm just trying to wonder if it goes
back to a place in you that like
resonates in other areas of your life
you know you a psych major
I don't know I just like to think about
you are I think like you know I just
think it's kind of fascinating you know
cuz you like you know a lot of guys have
you know gone through fighting and bent
and had an experience in that world but
you like kind of seem to also attack
like kind of the business world and I
continue to you know just keep whatever
your motivation was or maybe to fight I
don't know but you keep that motivation
just cruising right into whatever the
next thing absolutely so I guess I'm
just wondering like if organization is
one of your skills if there's like our
organization is not one of my skills I
do I think if I take it back
I do remember my mom always saying you
know she's saying you're really lucky
you got you're blessed with good teeth
you better take care of him you guys
like all that kind of stuff since I was
little so maybe at some point that stuck
in I just dad took care of she also you
tell me if I wear too tight of underwear
that my wiener wouldn't grow really
which I don't know if that's true or not
but I think she's you know I was a guy
that likes to keep old [ __ ] ya know my
old shoes might they try to give me get
rid of my shoes and my favorite shoes
throw them away and is it I go back and
get on oh wow it's just a comfort thing
this shirts like nine years old so if
something works you stick with it
absolutely yeah yeah didn't know when
you were fighting and stuff did that
change in in your fighting style or do
you feel like the fighting style that
you had when you started was kind of the
same because I know you've just kind of
you know I don't ever want to say any
somebody's finished from something but
finished a year ago I retired yeah
retired retired a year and a half ago
was your sno-isle always the same my
intensity was always the same but style
changes and especially in a sport like
ours and like you said I don't know how
much you do or don't know about about
the sport I know you love it and not
super much I'm excited though and I'm I
admire the fact like you know I've
always been kind of like I guess afraid
to defend myself where I grew up that
way without like a lot of like
you know somebody teaching me how to
defend myself let me know when it was
okay to defend myself or anything like
that you know what do you think that
comes from so I think it probably just
comes from you know we grew up in like
kind of a scary area and we just not
having like a father you know like a
that kind of over yeah strong figure my
brother moved away so kind of maybe some
of that yeah and be enough just probably
afraid you know like um but anyway so I
admire that you guys can do that like it
to me it's it's like it's fascinating
you know when they say they say that two
of the most feared things in human
beings period yeah is a physical
confrontation in public speaking yeah
which you got the public speaking down
right that's good on this yeah it's a
shame
it's weird to think about that for me
for you know 13 years of my life and
before that is wrestler my day was
filled with fighting guys that are also
some of the best guys on the planet so
you get rid of that real quick but it's
also something that can be scary that's
why it's probably so intriguing to
people yeah same with the reason you can
get up and be funny and and not afraid
to introduce yourself like for some
people that's a scary scary thing yeah
it's very individual so why don't you
talk about like has things changed as a
fighter especially when I first started
I was coming from a wrestling background
I wrestled in college at UC Davis and I
had to uh you know make ends meet mm-hmm
I was bussing tables and coaching kids
wrestling and making a couple hundred
bucks to win and just having fun with it
really and then follow my passion so I
definitely changed as a fighter skill
wise I got better with things but the
same mentality is is is important you
got to just believe in yourself and
people get knocked down on that kind of
stuff like you may think you're the
you're the funniest dude in the world
you get up there and you can't get
anybody to laugh and then like ah crap
maybe I'm not the funniest guy maybe
that shakes your confidence or else you
just like I am the funniest guy but you
know blame it on some of these guys
aren't they don't understand I wasn't it
or I need to hit another I needed
practice my jokes better or whatever I
got to keep that mentality that you've
got something and then and then change
it around so fighting style
a lot throughout time but same mentality
same is it is it is is fighting the kind
of sport where you're hot with your most
everyone is pretty is humbled pretty
often usually um are those humbling
moments there's ton of humbling moments
every day there's humbling moments but
you have to be a little bit delusional
also I think you know you talked about
Conor McGregor yeah you got to be a
little bit delusional I don't think you
know people like Oh cuz I know him I was
on a TV show with the guy I remember
seeing this yeah yeah there and all that
stuff and they're like is he faking it
for this and that I'm like no he he's
he's a funny guy yeah he's a confident
guy he's mouthy he's got a little bit of
a temper and he really really believes
all the stuff he's saying right you know
and I and I've got a he's almost
delusional to a point yet like to a next
level delusional of success delusional
to a point of success which is you know
you got to be that we may look back and
see him so like even in these clips and
he's you know in the clips when you guys
were in the UFC show and he's all yeah I
mean he shows looks like P we [ __ ]
Herman oh it's crazy he looks like a
pimp in [ __ ] like in on Martha's
Vineyard you know but do you think that
he like even at this time he had this
kind of bigger vision or he was just
like maniacal or not it's just like me
or anyone else it's become a world
champion on that level right and Inc had
this type of success you envision it you
believe it you're thinking it's gonna
happen and you know it's just matter of
fact like it's going to happen and he
had that from young age there's a video
of him maybe you guys can find it when
he's a kid saying I'm gonna be a
champion of the world I'm gonna have
more money than I know what to do with
and he just you know got pimples and
shaved head and it's cool to see you
know that kind of stuff come true
because I had the same visions yeah like
yeah and you fall I mean did you fall it
I mean you were just always fighting
yeah forty-four five was the world
champion and you know at the highest
level when when I was twenty something
years old and I maintained it for a
while as the top contender my entire
career had a lot of tile shots
even when the UFC came the UFC and the
WC merged so I was the WC in the UFC the
UFC owned the WEC
and all the light waiters from the light
weight fighters from the WC so when they
merged I won in the UFC I was 32 at the
time that kept going after that title
and having title shot so you know 13
years I was in the top three in the
world and and had a lot of fun doing it
yeah that's that clip oh wow yeah oh
that's Conor yeah my dream is to be
world champion world lightweight
champion in the UFC have more money than
I know what to deal with and have a
great life for my my kids my grandkids
everyone in my team my family everyone
that's that's come up with me that's my
dream my dream is to be number one
pretty much my girl isn't I'm number one
MMA we just basically spells out what's
happening right now well it's cool did
you like whenever so if you start to
look at like success like that like
really envisioning it and I think
everybody probably hope has like an idea
of success yeah do you think that in
your own life that you saw like a vision
of success do you think that success is
just something you can't like constantly
seen like come to you through effort
like what do you kind of feel like
successes in your life because you've
had successfully I'm fighting but now in
businesses right that's a great question
and I talked about this if I ever give a
talk motivational speech or talk to a
big company I you know I just basically
have a conversation with them and for me
and for a lot of the successful people
the same common things come up and it's
a thinking big process you can work hard
you can be smart you can you know get up
after you get knocked down and all this
stuff that's all important but how big
is your vision and I remember I was
working at a wrestling camp in in Tahoe
I worked there when I was a freshman in
college all the way through into my
career as a as a champion and mixed
martial arts and everything you know and
I was a freshman or I think a freshman
and I was a my first year out of college
so this is right after wrestling a date
right after wrestling at Davis and I was
up there coaching and I had traded a
a pair of shoot shorts for the CD that
this this kid burned me and I did
cassette tape with a cassette tape that
hooked up to a ghetto CD player and I
put that CD player in there and it was a
song it was going I'm gonna be bigger
than Jesus and bigger than wrestling and
bigger than the Beatles and bigger than
breast implants I'm gonna be the biggest
thing to hit these little kids bigger
than guns and bigger than cigarettes and
I just bought a $350 car because I had a
other 400 car that broke down and I left
what kind of car was it it was I think
it was a Datsun B 310 it had like
triangle windows and it beeped when I
backed up that was one of them I can't
remember and the car was shaken I had
this little cassette thing with the
thing and I had this CD and I was just
envisioning being on TV and I had had
like two fights and any casinos I got
paid like 500 bucks to show up but you
could feel that fight he started to feel
the fire I feel fired I was just
envisioning like but this isn't this
isn't 2004 when there was no it wasn't
that big that there wasn't even as big
of a league yeah there's three fights a
year with the UFC the lightest weight
class 170 pounds the biggest name guys
were getting pay like 150 grand if they
won the whole thing and and what weight
were you at at that time 133 pounds so
you would have to even you'd have to get
up to that weight TV I'm Pete
so my first fight was III just eaten
everything I could to weigh 149 pounds
and that's after I wrestled in college
133 and so I was that's this big to you
in 49 and and then I fought it 155 for
my first fight and I fought this big
Mexican kid do you feel fat when you
walked in the ring on it's like an
obvious Lee we're in shape but to put on
that much weight it that's a lot that's
like a 20% of your body because I was
already cutting weight for 33 so we're
we're put we're cutting down all this
weight and then putting it back on 159
you said yeah 149 I was I was eating to
do that but I was I was you know ripped
I was a specimen at that time especially
and and went in and I just remember I
got scared I didn't get scared but I got
nervous for the first time when I saw
the casino we drove on the Indian casino
because it was illegal in California the
time
and I remember the hair stuff you're
driving out of country - out of out of
the state to do Indian casino we're
joining we're doing that that is it was
the only place that was legal because
sovereign land it was actually in
California wasn't that far from me but
we had to go where where they could do
whatever the hell they want on the
reservation and I'm getting paid two
hundred bucks to show up two hundred
bucks to win I sold like you know twenty
tickets I gave me an extra 50 bucks and
I fight this big Mexican guys got pride
tattooed on his stomach and I remember I
poke a prod you know just regular pride
uh yeah I think it was regular fried
yeah I mean you don't hate yeah gay
pride - no dude I have this group that
came bus it was gay fist fighting that
would come to the bars in Louisiana it
was a couple gay guys get in there uh
[ __ ] dude no boys in Thailand uh-uh
dude there's a whole like like trend of
every once in a while like every like
year to like a [ __ ] just comes up and
whoops people's ass really there's
actually a movie about [ __ ] oh wow
chick who like made it to the loom
booyah stadium which is like the Big
Show and like was [ __ ] dudes up but
she's all you know it's like a it's like
a like a super accepted thing over there
and yeah and it's like oh are you you
know like they're trying to do it here
in America
you know everybody like gender news
saying everything else like your hair
yeah like this hair but I but for some
sports I think like sometimes it's like
with some of that it's like everybody
it's like yeah support everything like
bill bird the other night was saying you
know they keep making everything also
for women which is fine yeah but some of
it is just like - it's not like he goes
but nobody goes to the WNBA games he's
like yeah you've had that in nobody goes
title nine title nine is is something
that all college athletes know about
yeah yeah it's when they decided to make
it mandatory that had to be an equal
amount of resources going to women and
men
yes scholars who do I think actually
yeah and it screwed everybody it screwed
a lot of men's sports and screwed
wrestling programs that screwed like
other things and so there's little
animosity there but it does make sense
that you know when we should get a
chance all yeah but sometimes it was
like you know the composite for
programs you know going down and then
they like throwing women's rugby and
there'd be a couple chicks that are
involved and like you know yeah and then
they got big girls are making them out
there just because or you know
overweight or something loaded you
number one girl I gotten stung by a
bunch of bees and they made her get out
act like you know I just need a couple
EpiPens and I you know I'm not playing
I've never we never experienced that
playing halfback for you guys you know
that's funny what if that was part of
the regiment you had to get stung by
bees to be a rug we put that I'd have a
little more I go watch that yeah you're
the area you grew up in Davis there's a
lot of rugby and stuff up in that area
like Derek Lee Davis that's huge rugby
yeah that's a big rugby country and it's
funny because I don't know how it is in
other countries but for here in the u.s.
it's kind of a rich kids sport yeah well
- yeah yeah it's it's offered it like
this school because I didn't have a
swimming team we didn't have a pool my
little town we're a rugby team we didn't
have water pool we didn't have polo we
didn't have anything you know it was
like the basics and fundamentals so
rugby you get a lot of tough guys in
there but they're usually you know
Jordan - yeah George Walt likes schools
like yeah GW dude I don't remember they
had to do you just reminded me of this
they would check for sinkholes cuz
Louisiana really isn't supposed to exist
you know that's where I'm from
no because I mean it's like New Orleans
is eight feet below so yeah yeah you
know so really it's like people you know
trying to like build a universe in the
bottom of a teacup you know and then big
get pissed when tea shows up you know
one of those a little bit of camel mile
and your shoulders and some of your
Furious it's like [ __ ] you built down
here but they had a dude they had this
company would test for sinkholes and
they used to pay kids they'd hook you to
a chain put a chain when you put the
center of your waste and have you walk
off in a field and that just pave that
size about an hour and if you felt right
they yank you back and yank you back up
wow I don't know like oh this is
dangerous land out here you know okay
that's funny that's some weird [ __ ] that
people used to do it was fun yeah I
think some of that was just back in in
like you know times were a little bit
different I'm 38 now so times were a
little bit more fun right um yeah that
that does sound like fun not not for the
kid yes not for everybody watching baby
and the people betting on it you know I
went to a I didn't a USO tour with
Carlos Condit Michael Bisping and BJ
Penn in like 2008 Wow it was badass we
once again pianist and that was
helicopters and we went to all these
different places and whatnot yeah I was
it was 2008 so there was we were at like
a fence and there was like the civilian
people that living in the desert and
there's about six kids that ran up and
it was like like a flock of kids they
come up and they're like hey hey try and
get our attention and this and that
what's your name what's your name
they're talking to Michael Bisping hmm
and Michael misery said my name is
Michael because kid goes my name is
Michael - Michael Jackson let me get
some candy like Mike was like looking to
go throw him some [ __ ] and everything
and then the the people were that the
military guys I don't feed the kids and
this and that and then I started telling
us back when it was unregulated that
they used to do all sorts of crazy [ __ ]
like they would tie like toys and candy
bars and stuff like that to ropes and
kids would go grab and then yank them
and stuff military guys well yeah then
they all got in trouble cuz then that's
meathead [ __ ] to do obviously but uh it
was weird to see that [ __ ] that
dynamic with these kids like they came
up and see visitors they come up and
talk and then and then a military dude
would show up and they like run like it
was like a flock of like it oh wow like
yeah like uh yeah almost like when the
zookeeper is yeah yeah and when it's
just like people watching here then they
see something dangerous and flock off
and then run back and try to get some
candy let me get a Pepsi let me be the
Pepsi I'm Michael Jackson I'm Michael
Jackson I wonder why they love Michael
Jackson huh I think they just know
Michael Jackson yeah he's got to be one
of the most famous what do you think the
most famous people on the planet are
like oh Jesus Christ Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson maybe mom Elvis Presley
Mary maybe that photo of Mary with like
the Baader of like oh yeah you know
where you kind of see the little cross
over her head maybe I'm just trying to
think of yeah like yeah we just hungry
buddy would see yah Manali
Muhammad Ali yeah Michael Jackson about
Tyson Tyson up there Tyson could be up
there
I don't know though I mean it's a good
question today yeah for this day and age
if you were to go over to somebody Arion
the rock day now the rock yeah the rock
he's in movies all over the world ariana
grande who else maybe I can't tell you
what ariana grande even looks like I
would well it's probably good I think
she's only 17 okay why but yeah
hopefully I can either he can't either
do you uh so now that you've had a year
and a half away from fighting like what
are things that you don't miss about it
you know that's a great that's a great
point there's a lot of things that you
don't miss about it really we're having
the same thing with wrestling it's
[ __ ] hard dude yeah I mean the
wrestling world is a grind then you get
the mixed martial arts cruel world and
and you're basically fighting people
every day so your body gets jacked up
you're cutting weight constantly you're
constantly having to you know nourish
injuries and things like that I don't
miss having to do the grind like forcing
yourself to do stuff when you don't want
to do it which some people don't do
anyways some fighters don't do that
right and those aren't the guys that are
the top guys but most guys are at the
highest level have to do a lot of [ __ ]
that you don't want to do to accomplish
some of the things that you do want out
of life okay so stop so I want to stop
you right there and just say so when
those moments arise where it's like you
don't want to do something what are some
what were things that you use or things
you did to do like that contrary action
to motivate myself yeah no I didn't know
you want to do it I mean just first off
that the the bigger picture you know
looking at looking at what I wanted I
wanted to be a world champion or I
wanted to have this house where you know
material things we're having the the
family that you want right um I just
think about the things that motivate me
and all the benefits that come to being
the being the best at something yeah
yeah no that's a great point like if
you're laying there you think [ __ ] I
mean my alarm just went off I don't want
to go to the gym well of course you
don't want to go to the gym right but do
you want to go to the future that has
you feeling of Chi yeah but you don't
want to be be able to go sit and by the
ocean and
in a cool place in Mexico yeah and drink
some beers is my chick or my buddies
right I have to be working a regular
[ __ ] job
Yeah right because that might get you
over that hump of yeah I might not want
to go to the gym it's easy to say I
don't want to go to that yeah but is it
easy to say that I don't want to go to
that bigger picture yeah and I and
that's for me is is the the part I
enjoyed is you know I like the challenge
challenge is great I still for my for my
workouts mmm I'm still getting in and
competing with the guys that are top
dogs right now maybe you still train
like your I do but just for jiu-jitsu
most I'm trying to get hit in the head
as much yeah because that's something
that you have to do is you have to get
your sparring in and stuff like that so
I do a lot less sparring every once in a
while spar that means it's actually
punching you're kicking and elbowing or
needing that kind of stuff and I'll do a
lot of grappling I ground a tent align
it where Eddie Bravo is I've never been
that we just competed against him though
you did in quintet really your gym
competed against his yeah my team
competing against this team to be fair
mm-hmm
his team was like a purebred team of his
guys and we had some some outside guys a
one guy in particular Gordon Ryan who's
like the best in the world that we
recruited on our team because we didn't
have a heavyweight guy and we won the
whole thing
Wow but they won the one prior to that
and so it's kind of a cool little
robbery I mean not a fun rivalry oh yeah
yeah absolutely anyway I was a paid gig
it was it was televised it was it's a
big organization in Japan and now you
know it's on the fight pass it was
badass actually now is that that um I
know they just had a trade between who's
the fighter the Denise Johnson yeah
and Ben Askren yeah what do you think
about that everybody's talking about
that it's kind of cool
I mean trades the word trade has never
been again muttered inner in our sport
before right so the fact that they're
doing that is kind of interesting
mm-hmm one Fc is the biggest
organization outside of the UFC not here
in america but because they have so many
Asian influences earned like hundreds of
millions of Asian homes right and the
UFC hasn't necessarily been able to to
hit that market app that more focus you
know they've they've tapped the
International
but they didn't focus just on that okay
it's like you know there are specialists
when I see over there they cater to a
different you know different culture and
so uh actually Matt Hume who is the
trainer Demetrius Johnson he also runs
one of C so for that to have happened
it took some involvement with him I
think Demetrius had had you know been a
little you know disenchanted with the
UFC throughout the years he never was a
massive draw even though he's one of the
biggest successes in the sport as far as
winning so the opportunity for him to go
have a career in the Asian market
he's like a video game guy he's like an
anime guy too perfectly he's like a real
quirky you know fun guy it's it's
probably a better fit for him and I
think you know giving enough pushback on
the UFC mmm-hmm you know they've got
their ducks in a row yeah they're gonna
have to pay him a lot even though he's
not the champion do because he's built
himself up to that level so they may not
see the give and the get but it's
interesting yeah maybe that's gonna like
create a moment yeah I'd be great do you
think it would be is is are those two
leagues and you know I don't know that
much about it so are those two leagues
would it be a thing where every year
that they have a fighter that goes
against each other for like a it has an
overall like a new belt or something is
that everybody know it's a possibility I
would say probably not unless one buys
the other mm-hmm which I don't see
happening I see but but they have in the
past I know that Dana White went over
back in the day when pride was big pride
was like the big show in Japan it was
bigger than the UFC back in the day
mm-hmm and I know Dana had taken over
Chuck Liddell as a UFC representative to
go fight Alistair Overeem over in Japan
so there's been stuff like that you know
when you're doing with individuals that
are that have the say you could do
whatever the hell you want right that's
like negotiating with these guys it's
always like well we can't do that
against Paul Sam like Dana
like this is your company you can do it
you can do over the hell you [ __ ]
want Wow you know yeah it was Lorenzo
and Frank Fertitta well that's not
company policy and and but yet they bend
the rules all the time so bend them
could it happen
absolutely is this super rare yes and
also Ben Askren is a guy that talked a
bunch of [ __ ] on Dana White back in the
day and honey got himself banned they
said because he was too boring mm-hmm
which they say you know cuz he was a
wrestling like a racing bass guy but it
was really he talked to tonic [ __ ] on
Dana White Dana White on the UFC right
it was like you going to your bot your
future boss be like you're a [ __ ]
idiot yeah you thought you [ __ ] you and
your whole thing yeah it doesn't maybe
like hey can I get a job they're like I
know like Nick Diaz I know has always
been like outspoken kind of against
things and I think you know sometimes
just put him in like a tough spot you
know just put him in tough spot but you
know it's like you know I mean he speaks
from the heart you know I mean not
trying to switch to Nick or get you to
talk about that or anything but I was
firm being in a conversation with him
one time it was like very outspoken
about that sort of thing yeah that guy
wears it honestly man there's no faking
it with him and that's also the
unpredictability it's like playing Texas
Hold'em yeah and you got your cards in
the middle like my brother you know had
a little mental illness at one point
when he was just being unpredictable and
but he is smart as hell and didn't
really care and you don't know these
blood he knows how to play the game they
do unorthodox [ __ ] where he'd like
sometimes he'd go all-in and sometimes
he'd just fold or whatever you don't
know what the [ __ ] he's doing like it
made him a great poker made a great
poker player you can you don't know what
he's doing and that's the Diaz brothers
yeah like they really like will [ __ ] you
I'm not fighting like then everybody
wants to see if I'll slap someone in
public then everybody wants to see the
fight and like both funky we're not if
we said we're not fighting for the money
in there yeah then we'll go nine rounds
at a produce yeah wasn't like what is
yes they're one of the best fights is
when Diaz fought I forget the guys name
oh my gosh I can't move him forget the
name
they fought mm-hmm and Diaz lost the
decision even though I was frankly it
was Riggs Joe Riggs Joe Riggs and Nick
Dee
they fought each other in the ring in
like 2006 or something then they both go
to the hospital after a close fight that
I think Riggs got but Diaz 31 then they
fight in the hospital in the emergency
room one of the best before and after a
fight story and do they have the video
of them in the emergency room two
fighting I don't know when this probably
story of you if you look it up but it's
great uh so I think you can see them
like talking to [ __ ] me and held back oh
yeah you know what's funny is about uh
you know or what's it what's unique is
you're talking about this when I think
about Nate Diaz I think about him more
talking [ __ ] than I do fighting when I
think about him in my head it's like if
somebody's like Oh Nate Diaz the picture
that pops me in his head is like almost
yeah him [ __ ] you know yeah like him
being him and more than it is like a
like a memory of a certain fight of his
or something yeah it's kind of
interesting cuz other fighters it the
same thing doesn't happen as much hey
you know when you think a cowboy you
think of a cowboy hat when you think of
the California kid you think of blond
hair smiling yeah when you think of Nick
and Nate Diaz you think of real fingers
and heads up top yeah so you know their
branding yeah they're trying or not
they're doing their thing yeah it's
almost pure in it's almost pure branding
yeah well actually like that was one of
the first fighter people that I ever met
was Nick Diaz well I was fascinated
well there's Nick and there's Nate yeah
yeah the brother was the one I want
friends of both of them yeah and they're
really different I mean they come off
they're they're one as unit when it's
them against the world yeah but like as
far as like getting to know them hmm
like Nate is way more mild than Nick
right he's a little bit more like you
know dependable as far as like showing
up in two places and whatnot yeah and
then Nick is like a savant like he can
tell you about health food and he can
tell you about jujitsu and you know his
fighting like like that's his thing yeah
but he's kind of out there sometimes
it's kind of a weird dynamic but there's
fascinating brothers man yeah they're
fascinating yeah one thing yeah but when
you said he Wars he wears his heart on
his sleeve man it's exactly what I
thought about him like I could like one
minute he was like the toughest guy and
one minute he was also like at the same
time kind of I don't want to say the
sweetest guy
I don't mean it like that but he was
like the most endearing endear yeah like
emotionally right there like it was it
was almost fascinating to be around that
I've never met anybody really like that
ya know I said it's a cool it's a good
dynamic I've always you know didn't for
those guys yeah hey you can't yeah after
talking to him I've rooted for him so
I've rooted for him and almost anybody
he knew so well in a weird way yeah
they're very endearing so now that now
that you've gotten out of fighting did
you start was there a point where you
started to like look at business after
did you start to like you know do things
preemptively
I did I definitely was pre-emptive of
the business and it was more out of a
means like if you look back at me from a
business standpoint my first business
was top of the line coaching PLC and I
started that when I was a struggling
fighter just graduating college I
basically was getting paid a couple
hundred bucks to show up a couple
hundred bucks to win selling tickets
I've been in Tahoe is that the pictures
no murder no Sacramento okay Sacramento
yeah so so I was coaching UC Davis
wrestling I was an employee for the for
the college making seven thousand
dollars a year working ten ten that's
that's we had a way below poverty sandy
that's sex trafficking yeah yeah exactly
so I'm doing that then I then I'm
bussing tables at Inc which is a little
late-night place sometimes so 4:00 in
the morning after wrestling practice I
go and I started TLC top-line coaching
I'm coaching kids at two different
schools on cash under the table and then
in the summers I'm working wrestling
camps and the wrestling camp I was
talking about making a you know a grant
or two doing that but for me I graduated
college with a great degree and I'm just
like I'm like living the [ __ ] dream
dude like I don't have a job right I'm
just hustling I'm working like 17 hours
a day but I just I'm skating by not
getting it I don't have a job right
right I see my appointments like I'm in
my apartments like 250 bucks a month I
a crappy little room in an apartment
with to my buddies from college and you
know yes every kind of attitude during
I'm oh yeah that seem like something you
must have had a real like almost a
disposition that you were born with or
something because yes some people would
look at that as like [ __ ] I gotta do all
this work it seemed like you were
looking at as like ah this is great yeah
a hundred percent and you know I
remember and I talked about before the
thinking big things like how big are you
thinking like the people I've met I met
billionaires and and successful movie
stars and musicians and and clothing
moguls and and you know all these
different walks and it's that that's a
the positive mental attitude is part of
it and then definiteness of purpose like
knowing what you want yeah like going
after that that that thing that you want
or having your vision for yourself and
all through high school and college I
had a late start in wrestling and I was
write down my goals and I don't know
what it wasn't in high school I would
write down my goals and I always wanted
to be you know an all-american top eight
in the state that was once I got to be
able to think that big but I never wrote
down be a state champion I don't know
why you know what I mean which is weird
it's it's you know no one else in my
school had gone to this thing but you
skipping a step by All American you're
skipping the step of state champion
right I didn't skip that step right
every got me and our Oh being an
all-american is top eight in the nation
topping the state right Oh top eat in
the state and then and then stay
chambers the winner was that champion is
the winner of that and I wrote down to
be top a as my biggest goal is it was
first to get to the state tournament
goal it's a big goal but it's not big
enough you know what I mean
like cuz I was working just as hard as
the state champions huh and I had the
gift set of a state champion mhm I was
you know I had I was doing action should
I get up in the morning I'd run to
school ran like 13 miles of school one
day
dude they this reminder they had a guy
on who was on the UFC the fight show
that you guys did what was a cone
Ultimate Fighter Ultimate Fighter they
had a guy named Sam a long time ago he
was like kind of this big he was from
Alaska and he went to Louisiana hoager
yeah
when I went to Louisiana State he was
there
and I remember he with this made me
think of this he would run across campus
with his girlfriend on his back in the
fourth row and you would see him running
across just to stay in shape and he was
the first person I ever met in my whole
life he was a really sweet guy that
talked about UFC and MMA and he would
when people heard him talk about it was
almost like listen to somebody like that
a compliment from a mountain like
talking about a rare thing they'd seen
in the woods yeah that's when it was
3,000 to you know 2001 yeah I would I
went to Sam huggers gym years back and
done a seminar for him but yeah that's
funny and it's true like you do these
extra little things and you're and
you're gifted athlete I was a really
gifted athlete yeah I was raised up
healthy and I but why did I not put down
champion only top eight right that's
weird then I went to college and I and I
I had lost the four guys in my state
tournament geez am I in my call in my
high school career yeah and that ain't
super great three of the guys three of
the guys came to the same college I went
to and which is crazy and then you know
so you were training so you were working
with champs pretty much every day I
wasn't a chance with the the the point
was I got there and when I when I when I
went to when I went there three of the
guys that beat me in high school and
place better than I did came to the same
school and I set a new set of goals
which is to beat those guys and beat the
other guys and this and that on my team
right yeah I started low started low so
low and I got to a point where I beat
out all those guys I earned myself a
scholarship I made to the national
tournament and then which was my goal
and then I wrote a goal to be an
all-american which was top eight again
why did not put number one yeah isn't
that bizarre so we're now looking back
in what is that because sometimes I'll
think about that kind of stuff like
sometimes like it's kind of weird like
you know I'll think about like you know
I want to be you know great right but
then I almost Gary to say it yeah but I
ain't but that's also I don't want this
is interesting cuz I'm trying to feel
this and think about this at the same
time yeah like if I say that I'm great I
don't want or if I think that I can be
great it's almost like for some weird
reason I'm if I'm ashamed to say that
yeah it's true it happens like I'm
trying to think of what that feeling is
that would make me you know like get a
problem like what's the fear to admit
that [ __ ] I want to be just what the
fear is this first off the fear it's a
double-edged sword if you never say it
there's no accountability it's a lot
easier not to say something because that
no one's gonna point and say hi you
[ __ ] you you failed damn it's just
like my relationship some minutes it's
just like I don't want to say like I'm
in this for them I put their brother
because wow that reason it's crazy it's
crazy that that commitment level and
realizing and that's what I realized
after my fight career I I went in and I
beat a guy I beat two guys that were
national champions the next year and all
Americans and this and that and this is
in wrestling it's in wrestling right and
so when I went to my my next phase of
life in my next thing I was gonna go
after which was unrealistic as [ __ ] and
I want that that's what I'm talking
about with thinking big why the hell
would I choose a career in in mine this
is 2003 it was illegal in California at
the time UFC fighting cage fighting
mixed martial arts yeah legal it was
illegal at the time in the biggest show
they only had a weight class of 170
pounds tonight and I was 133 pounds and
there's only three shows a year right
200 bucks was the prize and and and you
know what you said in the big pier in
the bit in the big show there's three
shows a year at the big event and the
biggest prize is 150 grand right and yet
here I am graduating college with a
degree from a great university and
saying I want to make this my career
now Dean housing ticketed stupid as that
yeah it doesn't well here's what I'm
have been here's my question is did you
think though that it was going to be an
actual career at that point or did it
seem like this is just kind of a wild
thing that's going on in the world right
now like you can't I mean you don't know
that it's gonna grow you know when
somebody asks you to come down to the
ballpark and play a game of like unique
six on six are you football or something
you don't know maybe yours later is
going to be the NFL
you know perception is everything and so
mind you tonight 2,350 grant is still
pretty good oh yeah it's like oh my gosh
that being said I also got my emerging
teaching 2018 that is still yeah yeah so
I also have my emergency teaching
credential I was gonna start substitute
teaching for like 11 bucks an hour right
then I took my first fight and I beat up
this kid and in a minute and a half and
forget that I had trained all through
high school and colleges wrestlers yeah
in my mind it was a minute and a half of
work and I got paid 100 bucks to show up
and I got paid 50 bucks I've made 450
bucks
almost 500 bucks in a minute and a half
that's why I saw this you look at all my
buddies there and a bunch of hot chicks
and and and I'm the center of attention
and I like got my endorphins going I'm
like this is [ __ ] it I'm going this
route this is it what you know like so
is it it's about perception now when you
have money in the bank and you're
looking at what the hell was I thinking
by the time it's interesting I was going
passion mm-hmm all passion and just
think it big a lot of people don't have
any skills man and oh well that doesn't
have to be you you know skills are
something that everybody you know wants
to have sometimes and Skillshare is an
online learning platform with over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
in social media marketing data science
mobile photography creative writing you
don't have to go back to college you'll
need a you know go to University of
Maryland or go to dang you know Johnston
and Wales or whatever you could just
take a class as Skillshare calm and go
get whatever you need in the world
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set start a side
hustle or just explore a new passion
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
and thriving you can get too much a
Skillshare for just 99 cents
that's right Skillshare is offering this
past weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to
for 20,000 classes for just 99 Skrill
eyes to sign up go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo again go to Skillshare
dot-com slash Theo to start your two
months now and get your skills I'm
trying to think well I'll get back on
that what I was saying so much but we
ended up at perception right yeah the
perception thing and perceptions
fascinating to me because that's I mean
it's something you talked about a couple
times you know like looking at the big
picture you know like and just
perceiving things like that because
that's the thing that I that I even
notice in myself and it's a constant
battle is when I'm in a good mindset and
I'm able to perceive the bigger picture
and actually like be brave enough to
even admit to myself that I want to try
and like yeah be great it's scary in
other moments where I get fallen yes
yeah yeah it's like it's it seems
fascinating to be great but it also just
yes something seamless well first off
really scary is other people keeping you
accountable then also you've said it out
loud then you also know to be great at
anything I don't care what it is it
could be you know anything I meant that
some of the best video gamers on the
planet and I got to talk to them about
what they're doing you know even you you
know I I stand it up on your path to
where you are now and it was you know a
lot of stuff over you know he has been a
long road 15 years yeah
and people get discouraged people get
tired of the hard work some people can't
can't do that push and so when you do
that accountability you say it mmm then
that changes things and that's what I
did when I got out of college I realized
so now I'm coaching at the college right
and I'm seeing guys that I beat that
that are all-american and national
champions and stuff like that and I know
that I've worked harder than these guys
cuz you realize you're in their
classroom you realized ya beat them and
these are guys are doing well yeah and
I'm like why did I not put down the
champion thing so I've set my new goals
I'm living in my little apartment
bussing tables at ink coaching kids and
I'm coaching wrestling working like 17
18 hours and and I wrote down my goals
it was
be a world champion at the time it was
UFC or pride because those are the two
big organizations
I said own two houses the next three
years and that's hard to do but the rest
yeah and then I said that's all you
think owning two house is harder than
being the world champion
well I mean this is where we talk about
perception and then and then the last
one was ona a healthy and successful
business this is funny
it's like CEO saying about perception
right well [ __ ] that's very easy to be
the world champion of the hardest for in
the world but you want to own two houses
are you crazy been in LA too long do you
think that's what it is that's it these
LA prices it would seem a lot more free
yes come to Sacramento yes Bob man let's
so we have questions that came in from
some fans we round up boarding our
conversation but I just want to chop
some in here and there you can put these
headphones on actually cool and you'll
be able to hear one of the ones that
came in thank you to you by the way I'm
liking Andre feely
he's got them hands boy he got them
relaxed Cobras on the end of his [ __ ]
arms little nubs by the way I'm sorry
anyway two questions guys real quickly
do you have any books or conditioning
tips or anything that you would
recommend that I can read and take in
for my first fight I'm trying to get it
by mid-january
thank you in advance as well any tips on
real real estate investing you know
anything that you know you wish you knew
when you started getting into your
guyses monetary endeavors you know I
mean that could go for both you I
appreciate it thank you very much for
everything that you guys do huge fan
again gang gang baby rat king till the
day I die
damn bro ah wow thank you boy uh it is
my boy I hope you hope everything's
doing okay now I'm excited
he's more fired up about a lot about my
life than I am yeah but those questions
are almost it's almost crazy that's the
questions that came in because we just
stopped right here on real estate so and
I know that's part of the world that
you're in right and so what were his
questions again one was a
got any real estate investing advice
that you wish you had known earlier
right and then he said also any good
books or things that you should do to
prepare for a fight and yet fitness and
he also said what's up to on Jay
touchy-feely yeah you'll love Audrey
feely will get him on the show at some
point he's unique character is he unique
mofo really got outcast and underdogs
music label and it's clothing that guy
looks like an outcast and underdog oh
that's perfect this guy he must be a fan
he said that it was yeah he's a fan of
his but uh there's a lot of good books I
mean there's I like Napoleon Hill you
know he wrote three thinking good
thinking but he has the also the laws I
figured the I figured the rules of
success so he talks about positive
mental attitude and yeah there's a with
him yeah touchy feely I just produced a
movie and we put feeling in it he kills
I'll show you guys the trailer this
mango what is it uh is that the movie no
no it's called green it's called a green
fever it's not out yet okay yeah I got
him I was just in the Rock's movie you
were yeah I was sick but let me get back
to this guy yeah get back to this so
even outside of book so what are
practices I think that part you know
like because anybody can know a book I
want to know what you know I would say
for for a guy like that he seems like
he's passionate and happy dude you gotta
understand about commitment levels and I
talked to uh there's coach Lee Kemp he
has a book hmm it's called I think
winning gold
he's what three-time world champion
that's a good one anything you can read
on Dan Gable that's another guy who's
yeah he was one of the best wrestlers I
suppose both Li camp and Dan Gable were
both to the best best leaders of all
time and the commitment level these guys
had is what set them apart it's decided
they're gonna do something and then just
just going after it so those are two
things and then I would say you know you
got to put yourself in uncomfortable
positions some people hate to run I like
to run I mean I I hate to run the way I
run because I run until I'm like
fatigued in a short period of time and I
would do some some hard pushes where
your lungs are blown out do five minute
rounds as fast as you can for as long as
you comment around the what running
three rounds yeah yeah of five because
he's probably fighting he's probably
gonna fight 300
that's that fear running right or you
could give somebody a [ __ ] hatch in
your neighborhood to do this trap you
know I can't run from that dude right
yeah if you wanted to get old-school
with you know do that hat do those
hatchet runs so is so so those are some
of the things you say like physically
that the guy could do to start to
challenge himself
yeah and I and I would say you know I
just I just watched a TED talk when I
got over here hmm look for as many of
these motivational things you can get
because it all ties in together like
we're talking about mmm you know you got
to believe that you're gonna win you
really got to believe it in your heart
and then you know you have to go out
there and do it so I would say you know
get on some of these subjects on on the
Internet to start you know book on tapes
stay motivated stay motivated find
motivators find motivators and then get
yourself out of your comfort zone when
it comes to fitness and what not when
you got into business and stuff did you
start to realize like here's one thing
that I've learned like or started to
question and see that there's things
that I'm not good at and to let some of
those get help with some of those let
somebody else do some of those because I
come from this thing where it's like I'm
afraid to let anything go right like
it's just you have to know nature yeah
how did you did you have a moment you
came to that or you do you always kind
of was that always just part of your
flow I've always I've always been pretty
good at delegating just because I'm feel
like I'm real self-aware and I
understand my strengths pretty well and
I know some of my weaknesses and I'm
also not afraid to share in things so
which is sometimes it comes back to bite
you but as a general rule for me it's
worked out you know I'm okay to give
inclusive give something to someone yeah
to help motivate them as long as they're
pulling their weight and they're
like-minded and I trust and stuff like
that yeah we just gave me two raises
this year so nice yeah that's not bad
yeah we asked if we told me can't ask
for one for another year the best part
of the second one but the workload keeps
increasing so we may have to talk about
that right but yeah so for that
delegating delegating and then on top of
that just always just like the fight
game you're always trying to
and I've been learning that I've learned
I've taken some hard knocks in the
business world just like in the fight we
really and and it's been you know having
conversations like this I'm part of
something called a oh it's
entrepreneurial organization and I'm
like the low man on the totem pole we
meet like once a month there's I believe
11 of us in the group all from different
walks of business and we share
information we there's like a gestalt
way of communicating which means we talk
about our experiences not like giving
advice necessarily you have to like
speak from your own experiences oh wow
what you've done like oh like I have
this happening like oh I had an
experience that I can relate to where I
was doing this and someone tried to sue
me and you have to share your
experiences I learned a lot from other
people mm-hmm but the truth is like you
know business is 90% of the time just a
group of people and I mean there's
products and there's this and there's
that but you have to you know work with
managing people and be able to delegate
and be realistic what you're you're good
at what you're not you ever heard of the
shoestring millionaire the guy that you
know the guy that made something doesn't
ah I don't think so yeah we could Google
that though right no offense of
anybody's a rapist all right sorry but
no I don't know what I'm talking about
but I feel like murders and rapes always
get like some of the craziest things
some of the coolest names yeah Sally
millionaire the shushing millionaire
rapist yeah yeah I the whole backstory
of that is great well maybe we go friend
of me movie about it you could be the
right you sure yeah that'd be good I got
that yeah I'll be there catches you and
I could see that yeah the weird twist at
the end I rape you yeah and this is
where Nick's salary goes up so do you
have you found that you enjoy one more
than the other being a businessman or
being a fighter or do you find that
really they were the same thing and
you're just doing two different actions
I think it's kind of the same thing as
long as you're passionate about both you
know I've been
about the business side of things and
again I started out my business through
necessity I needed to start coaching
kids TLC right then I ended up doing
alpha-male shirts while I was selling
tickets and shirts to make raised money
when I was fighting right you already
selling a ticket let me tell you this
shirt as well then I started a gym when
I brought in a guy that that wanted to
start a gym he put up the funds I put in
all the sweat equity hmm my dad did the
construction for a cheap price I helped
you know you know dig holes and build
stuff in addition then I started
management company before anyone knew
who I was and then you know it spurred
into more and more things and just
learning out of necessity how to survive
on my own terms and for me that being a
businessman is the same as is the fight
game it just allows me to live the life
that I want to live on my terms when I
when I want to do things who I want to
be with nice huh you know that kind of
thing and that's that's what I'm always
fighting for and that's what I'm always
pushing for is the ability to do that
for the rest of my life and of course
you have to do stuff like we talked
about that you don't want to do yeah in
order to do the things that you want to
do but you want to try to get those down
as minimal as possible over time mm-hmm
like Joe Rogan is a good example of that
yeah I mean that's a guy that he loves
[ __ ] fighting yeah he loves making
people laugh he loves interesting weird
[ __ ] like talking about is curious yeah
new martial arts yeah whatever and
that's how he gets paid and time travel
I have a feeling he might arrive that
low-key he has a dude in his warehouse
[ __ ] tinkering with clocks right just
gonna [ __ ] his set a watch you know you
might be your dad what if he already
went back and he's your dad what if one
day he just shows up with a tattoo of
his family on his arm and I'm in one of
the pictures yeah he is a pass any man
one one of the gifts I noticed he has is
the constant ability to stay curious
about things he's curious about
everything you know yeah
and he genuinely is like it's almost I
don't know if that's a gift or something
that he nurtured over the years but yeah
he has the ability to stay curious about
everything but also yes he's
created a life where that fits the life
that he wants right
like he doesn't take on like television
shows and that kind of [ __ ] like yeah
they're always throwing that stuff
towards him you know but he's like I'm /
this is what I want yeah doesn't he
wants yeah and that's that that's
through a lot of hard work and
dedication and probably doing some
things he didn't love to do it points
here and there and and finding his way I
had a conversation with him one time it
was about I think he's talked about it
where he was talking about you know
getting involved in buying our team and
we had a conversation this and then I
got mad at him for something he said on
one of my fights and it was a stupid
immature conversation we were having and
it was just me and him yeah and at the
end of the day he goes man I don't care
about money he goes the whole reason he
was I don't do things for money he goes
the whole reason I had you have [ __ ] you
money so you can say [ __ ] you I don't
want to do it which is awesome it is I
like him a lot and he he's been a he's
been a you know a big part of the mixed
martial arts world for a long time yeah
yeah it's interesting we kind of uh you
know we were just talking about this
earlier that if there was ever like um
like if the world was gonna end and
everybody's gonna listen to one guy like
were we all gonna meet up at yeah I feel
like it would be Joe Rogan yeah like if
Joe Rogan is like hey I'll see you guys
in Denver in six days well you at least
well I don't know about that like I
would I would say I would count that he
wasn't trying to hoax us yeah I say go
there and he's I count that I would I
trust that he wouldn't do that but do I
know that that I believe that his idea
is the best I don't know yeah he gets us
some [ __ ] tangent sometimes when I'm
like are you serious like what's this
what is this coming from
yeah I remember he asked you one time
and the hardest thing sometimes is to
keep up with like what's going on when I
go in his podcast like it's hard to like
yeah he just likes to think he's like
you think you're the only Theo von out
there I'll tell you what you're not the
only Theo though yeah my dad's Theo is
he really that's my dad's name oh wow
Theodor Faber he's first generation
American from Holland yeah it sounds
very that's Dutch you guys are done yeah
oh dude the Dutch I'll say this most
aerodynamic people in the world
yeah usually kind people really kind
people - oh the decent Dutch they call
these dumb and very cheap for my other
really yeah going going to Dutch man you
make the chicks favorite pairr share
yeah making ladies pay for half of and
they're also the tallest young people on
the planet and I ironically got my short
side for my 4 foot 10 great-great
grandmother or great-grandmother on the
Dutch side and my Italian grandfather
was nearly 7 foot tall dang though I so
grow I just got lucky
you never know never I never have to hit
my head on anything tall limber and
quick yeah that's true you can also you
can be Halloween things you can be
things that Halloween that other people
can't be exactly you know jump out of
weird stuff yeah you can add on
somebody's here you could hide on let's
go to a call actually actually about a
call I think's gonna figure so hey this
is Noah appear in Cleveland I'm huge
fans of you both and I have a question
for Uriah I'm particularly not a very
tall guy and I know you're not either
and I was just curious if growing up if
you ever add like little man syndrome or
if your size or stature ever affected
you in any way
alright gang gang Thea see you're right
brother nice guy you know what I yeah
that never really I never really had had
that and I think it's because I'm
delusional yeah you know whatever I've
been known for that my guys make fun of
me and this and that think I did a great
practice when I got my ass kicked or
something like that but uh you know my
brother's 511 my sister's five nine G's
hoggin inches yeah you could be five six
babe and help you freaking rippling out
yeah and I yeah but I never have it I
didn't really have it no and I think it
was because I always got treated with a
lot of respect than ever I never really
was the guy that got picked on
yeah I had to gift the gab I also was a
good athlete when I was young I used to
do a lot of like I used to do
commercials and like runway monitor
tiny'mons money that kind of stuff so I
always had a lot of confidence but I
will say you know I have I have
experienced like just other people
thinking that way like it
it would be shocking to me when
something be like oh how is it you know
like mention it and I'm like I just
doesn't factor to me I remember I had a
training camp back in 2005 there was
Tito Ortiz Randy Couture was out there
Frank Trigg Quinton Rampage Jackson
James Sandman Irvin Scott Smith we do
right here extra man interrupt yeah all
these guys all the all these all these
individuals that were there at this
event and in Frank Trigg was the
smallest one but he's a 70-pound in the
UFC which means he walks in 70 pounds
170 oh you use 170 pounds yeah I'm like
where is he like your cousin is that guy
Oh daddy long that a magnitude he's our
company he actuator he just hit like 90
pounds but 70 pounds on my cruise about
these fights but I remember all the
other guys were big guys right right
like heavyweights and light heavyweights
and he was a1 170 pounder and I told him
I said hey bro tomorrow I got a bunch of
guys our size coming
mm-hmm and remember I was 133 pounds and
he goes would you stop saying that you
and I are not the same size that's
afraid trig told me I like damn I guess
you're right and then all see pictures
on back guys got my side yeah like I
thought that with Tom Hardy Tom Hardy
I'm like Tom Hardy's about my size and
Dan Bilzerian I'm like dude Dan
Bilzerian is my size and then I'll see a
picture next oh my god this is so crazy
cuz this all is like his perception man
like you your perception is this bigger
picture percent yeah I mean of yourself
yeah even even unrealistically like that
I mean I literally I was like dude I met
Bilzerian this is years ago yeah and I'm
like dude bilzerian's sure me he's my
size and then I told someone like oh
yeah he's just a little guy it looks
bigger on you know and videos and
everything and then I and then I later
took a picture to send to my my buddy of
me and Dan and I'm like oh wait
nevermind he's company's got me
different height is there between the
two you know I can look it up right
about but it's kind of messing that is
yeah it's almost like a D like
just having that ability that bigger
person but not only having a bigger idea
but having that bigger idea like
infiltrate that your perception right so
the bigger idea almost it's not just a
thought it's like this more yeah more
rounded thing that lives in you right
you ever what's the what's the book what
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest the book
they would Jack Nichols so Jack
Nicholson yeah
one blue Kuzon yeah One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest and the Indian guide never
talks yeah yeah we had to read that book
in school and the Indian guy saw Jack
Nils Jack Nicholson Nicholson's
character as so much bigger than he was
mmm just because it was just he had a
presence about him you know I think
maybe I have that going for me I don't
know these are definitely been moments
where I've been in some fights before
right where you're from different I mean
street fights I'm talking about where
you're from different like when I got to
college I couldn't a small town and I've
also been went to the same elementary
school for from kindergarten to sixth
grade everybody knows who you are you
know there's like there's an awareness
of who you are no one really messed with
me I wasn't a big fighter growing up but
don't mess with me that's I mean if they
would be in a fight probably right
didn't happen but you were not picking
fights you weren't that more like an
[ __ ] cuz I was like you know just a
person yeah just just nice guy we lived
in a small town and I remember getting
to college getting the bar scene and
everybody has different rules of
engagement too there's a kid from the
rich area in San Fran there's a guy from
the ghetto there's a guy from the small
town but for me I'm not used to somebody
get my face and trying to Punk me for no
reason right you know I've gotten a
couple of great fights with guys that
just were playing with different rules
and had no clue who the [ __ ] I were like
too little too late you know like
something in somebody's neighborhood you
can sit right in front of someone dangle
your face and talk [ __ ] and like touch
noses in other people's neighborhood as
soon as you step into a certain area
you're getting hit that's true it's so
interesting it's interesting that it's
like the the mesh pot of people that
come together you add alcohol to that
yeah and egos and chicks around and
whatnot yeah oh my gosh that's SEC
football yeah yeah yeah but I know
that's interesting that the different
people have different rules of
and also use the term that I've never
thought of great fight was a term I used
up I can't even imagine putting those
two words so when some of the first time
you like if you get hit it doesn't I
mean I can imagine at a certain point
like if I get hit in my face bro like I
would be you know first of all have a
big nose so like that's definitely any
hit no matter where they hit me I'm
[ __ ] getting grilled in the [ __ ]
beak you know no but it's like that
would like I feel like just really won't
make me want to shut down does that kind
of go away a little bit were you able to
stomach that a little bit more well yeah
because you know how to take a punch I
mean there's a lot of things to think
about but first off pain is is a
different thing for you because you've
experienced probably I've experienced a
lot more pain than you have right
physically yes through my career the
other thing is understanding how to
position my body how to mitigate the
actual damage done whether I'm getting
hit hard or barely slipping a punch or
whatever that changes the the the
ability to be aware of what's actually
happening they say that's not the punch
that you see coming it's the one that
you don't see coming that's because your
brain doesn't know what the hell is
happening when your brain sees that
coming and it goes okay I just got hit
and it can function that but if you just
get hit your body's not as a custom so I
see you're used to that I know how to
body use my position my instincts will
allow me to deflect the blow a little
bit in the correct way not just follow
instincts that are human mm-hmm actually
train instincts by professionals and
then it's not as big of a deal right and
I actually actually know where to hit
somebody right if you guys are curious
where to hit somebody if you want to
knock him out or hurt him yes you hit
him in the chin mm-hmm and the upper lip
in the jaw right here you can sometimes
do damage if you can get a guy in the
temple or the back of the head but you
don't want to hit them around here this
is where you're gonna get your hands
broken by hitting somebody right which
I've done before and so you know that's
like I I was it I just had Bradley
Martin you know Bradley Martin is you
know that he's a YouTube YouTube guy
this guy he came out and was on our
podcast and he and he came out to the
gym he
like 300 million views on YouTube Wow he
can do some crazy stuff he's an athlete
he's a 260-pound guy he's he's like a
real athlete that talked me in a
bodybuilder but he's a he's a he's a
real character too and a business guy so
fascinating you know we're talking about
you know the fitness stuff and it's it's
like he's like I think I want to learn
how to do this and do that and he's like
do you think you can beat me up and I'm
like I'm Mike I mean there's only one
way to find out you know and then I just
guess and I'm like I'm like I said you
ever train anything is no and then so we
had like a little bit of a debate of
like well I would just pick you up and I
just slam you down in elbow you and I'm
like all right well I had that
experience where I had this conversation
with a 300-pound guy before he played
football Davis we were both washing
washing the courts in for work and the
tennis court in college and we're out
there we're talking about this subject
and he said I just grabbed you by your
neck and I would just grab you by your
neck to pick you up and slam you and i
and i'm and i'm Division one wrestler at
this time and he's that little star
football player like a defensive lineman
yeah our offensive line and this ain't
Tom and Jerry either no Eric trollee
actually if you're out there with
somebody and and so we're out in the
courts washing in and I've got my shoes
off and my shirt off I'm just wearing
shorts and he's in there and and he's
got his shoes on whenever we're talking
he goes I go I go what makes you think
I'm gonna let you grab you by the neck
and throw me only gonna goes I'll just
grab you by the neck are you on the
ground listen Ed so this culminates and
me and him getting into it on the cement
and he's 300 pounds and I'm 140 pounds
and I get behind him like this and he
and he goes and he and he does like a
barrel roll and I slammed my hip and I
end up choking the guy out at the end I
mean it took him unconscious made him
tap yeah and then my hip was all hurt
and we both felt like idiots afterwards
everything else but now it's telling
Bradley this and he's like I guarantee
you I can I can pick you up and slam you
within a minute and I I all right he's
in a bar barely City
injured at this time right badly is and
so so you guys hit the mat so he's like
I can't cuz I'm injured this now but
we're gonna do it we're buddies we're
gonna do at some point so I'm like well
let me just get up and I go let's just
feel I want to feel what you feel like
like you know grab each other you know
move around and yeah it's not he's like
you get hits the ice pack off his knee
and he stands up and we start grabbing
each other like this and yeah I I did
something that set him off Wow and he
goes in for a double and then he goes in
and grabs me and we almost go to the the
mirror and then he slams me on the
ground and squeezes me and I'm just like
like just chilling at this point and he
gets up about 5,000 bucks and I go what
that wasn't the competition like we were
getting up that was it he didn't he
didn't think that was it but he was into
it
anyone showing it was he flexing a
little trying to show his worth you
think we were just we just were having
fun and I got him I convinced him to get
up so I could like feel him yeah when he
could even though he's injured and he
said that I set him off by doing
something oh and so he went full mode
and and I wasn't going full mode at the
time and I'm next thing you know I'm
slammed on my back
there's 260 pound dude just like flexing
on me it was the funniest thing could
you omit him tap at that moment yeah not
not that moment no but we're gonna find
out that's what we're gonna maybe
televise it yeah I was gonna say you got
a life dude but at least cool yeah it
was her it was so funny and I go I go
bro you just want to race it no one else
knew was a race well you set me off and
I go what IDs like you set me off and
I'm like alright whatever whatever we
had yet now it was it was hilarious dude
after you beat him I'll beat him this
guy I don't know we have we have a 1 a 1
minute set where we're gonna he's gonna
try to take me down I like that and
we're gonna do it and this guy is
impressive man I mean he can he can jump
he can like do pull-ups he's flexible
but he's 260 pounds and where does he
train he has his own gym out here that's
not that box and burn is it no it's not
boxing his is more about it's something
you know weightlifting it's like an
8,000 I think it's pretty close to here
I'll give you the information
or to shape man I'm starting to feel
ashamed to myself yeah I don't like when
Theo gets all fired up after we have a
fighter and he starts trying to fight me
because you guys pay for that contract
you guys leaving it's just me you know
and it was a premature baby he was born
like probably six weeks early you never
know what's gonna happen you talked
about it he talked about hip injury a
few minutes ago we had Dustin Poirier in
the other day you know oh yeah and I'm a
big you know fan of Dustin's and you
know he's a nice guy and he just wants
to be the champ you know he just yeah he
loves to fight yeah do you and he he
took out of the Diaz fight because of
hips he got stem cells put into his hip
is that like a normal thing how is that
kind of review like veered and the fight
world is that the same choice that you
think you would make if you know if
you're not in top shape do you step back
from a fighting wait till you are like
that seems to be like a choice that's
most likely to be made um yeah depending
on how bad your injury I've gone in a
fight I mean the truth is and Dustin
knows this you're never gonna go into
any fight 100% right but there's you can
always have Nicks and bruises and maybe
little injuries and stuff like that and
I've had fights in the past I mean after
I lost my first fight and the smaller
shows I fought seven times in one year
on these little reservations making a
thousand bucks here 500 bucks here you
know that was how as part of how I was
making a living at the time and there's
more of a necessity but ya know when
there's a lot at stake you want to give
yourself the best chance and the best
chance of recovery and everything else
yeah you know III would say if the
injury is bad enough absolutely yeah
step out and try to nourish it back
because you know it's higher stakes now
it'sit's a big deal that every single
fights the most important one in your
life when you look back on your career
was there a fight if you could go back
and redo one fight is there one or even
a moment in a fight that you get that
plays in your head sometimes um you know
even as a comedian I have some moments
in my head that like oh man like you
know I take the Netflix special that I
really didn't like you know yes the
pieces didn't come together right and
and I wish I could go back and do that
over yeah do you have a moments like
that deal yeah quite a few actually yeah
and I know you know it's 44 fights I've
had
somewhere you're more inspired than
others especially me at a time when I
was the pioneer for the lightweight
fighters and my name was the biggest and
every in in the sport for for my weight
class yeah it's like every single fight
I had everything to lose like everybody
wanted to fight me etc and it was
sometimes hard to get up for these
fights that no one knew who it was and
everything else so I've had some
lackluster performances at times and
then I've also had some some
performances where I've had some bad
injuries like I hit Mike Brown on the
top of the head in the first round and I
shattered one bone and I snapped the
other one in a five round title fight
and I remember going back to my corner
and tell my trainer he didn't speak any
English hey my hands no good and he told
me to shut up
champion hit through the heart and I go
and fight five more rounds like that
third round I dislocated my thumb
the first fight against Mike rounded
like a jumping back fist and overhand
right like I mean there's been a lot of
moments where like oh man I wish I could
do that again you know yeah
none of those but at the end of the day
it was always max effort was it was
exhausted and that that's comforting at
least yeah do you you know I was talking
with Dustin about this um about the fact
that I was looking at some photos him
after some fights and I didn't know what
fights they were that he'd been in you
know and I was just
he looked no matter what he looked like
he'd gone through it's almost like it
seems like to a guy who doesn't fight or
can't fight that you go through like a
win or lose it's like you win
yeah those like win or lose just that
you test yourself that you test your
mettle at that point against another man
that that that that is enough of a win
in the end that it over it outweighs the
actual fact if you win or losing yeah
and there's guys who make whole careers
like that I think Donald Cerrone Clay
Guida you know those guys in particular
have have made careers like that where
where they're in it becomes staples in
the sport because every single time they
lay it all out there and they put on a
great fight and they walk away you know
exciting yeah Joe Lauzon is another guy
Eddie Alvarez baby Alvarez eagle Sanchez
Diego Sanchez
those are guys that you know exactly
what you're gonna get when you watch
those guys fight they're gonna let it
all hang out their head blown off
I mean Nick and Nate Diaz yeah I mean
those guys in in and there's a lot of
scenarios I mean you can make a case for
every fight being like that but
obviously there's fights that stand out
I mean it's a tough it's a tough tough
way to to make a living once you've made
to the highest level yeah
then staying there and then actually
getting paid and then being smart enough
not to spend all your money and do dumb
things and go broke I mean there's a lot
of different ways you can screw up in
this sport do you do you have younger
guys reach out to you now since you have
had a success after you know not only
you know success in the ring in the cage
sorry but success actually afterwards in
business do you have young guys that
reach out to you now yeah we have a ton
of guys especially on my team I mean I
have guys that talk to me all the time
about about business that our peers in
the fight game and ask advice and stuff
like that you know help manage guys in
the past to help guide people on our
team we have a lot of guys that have
have started their own businesses chad
mendes for example he has his fins and
feathers hunting business mhm he spends
all his time when he's not training to
fight as an athlete he spends all his
time you know doing awesome hunts which
he loves to do and he's in his creating
a business around that andre touchy
feely just got him in his first movie
that I'm that I produced the green fever
movie we could play Machine Gun Kelly in
any movie it looks like yeah yeah yeah
he's he's got his own music label and
he's got his own clothing industry you
know his own clothing stuff Danny
Castillo has p2o hot Pilates business
and we have a lot of guys that have been
following in the footsteps and thinking
like that yeah yeah do you think that
that's um more of a like like I look at
some athletes now like I look at LeBron
James and it's like he's kind of too
much of a business for me
he's not it doesn't seem like as much of
a basketball player to me and this just
my perception I just look at him it's
like it's like watching something else
go on it's like watching an
advertisement sometimes every time I see
him touch the ball whereas
some players it feels like when they get
the ball oh that's a player with it a
basketball player do you feel like that
as you know the business side of it
becomes bigger that it starts to it take
away from the fighting side of it it can
I mean it can I mean it just depends
yeah it depends on the individual and
here's a guy Conor McGregor
I mean his his whiskey company is
probably gonna be friggin huge was it
property over 12 I mean that was just a
massive paid advertisement and really
what whiskey company if you look at guys
that have exited you know what who the
vitamin water was what 50 Cent's yeah 50
cent and then we have was just wasn't
Robert Downey jr. who did a rock was P
Diddy or somebody did he there was
what's name the actor who who sold his
his alcohol brand oh the tequila company
was billion dollar
oh yeah Robert oh no uh the guy he was a
doctor and I see Grayson at 11:00 every
Ocean's eleven yeah that guy George know
yeah this is the best this is the best
game you and me trying to guess
something yeah you've told it to kill a
company that made a ton of money the
actor George Clooney Clooney gang there
you go dude that hey bro fighters
against people that are like people have
been hit a bunch and then people who are
just not trying to guess we should do
our own trivia show not a bad show oh
you have a podcast too right I want the
name of that out yeah that's Cali cast
okay we've I was kind of stockpiling
some interviews that I've done over the
last year we just recently launched so
sweet and we talked about business stuff
fighting entertainment I've really been
getting into doing the movie stuff
lately I was in the Rock's movie just a
small part called rampage okay and then
I've got a slate of movies that I've
been pushing for you know some producing
some in Wow and what is that about is it
just do you see is it a cool business
thing is it something you just always
been intrigued by where does that start
beau
I'm an artist you know right martial
artists I any real estate stuff I've
done and when I have to still answer
that guy's question about the real
estate I skipped that has been there all
projects my dad's a contractor and he's
worked on five different projects for me
where I rip the place apart and rebuild
it with my vision the doctor hard
workers hard workers absolutely and and
so I like creating things and I've
always kind of been interested in that
and I've been learning the business over
the last nine years my manager Marc
Shulman he's a three arts here I started
learning from him years ago by him
trying to get opportunities for me I'm
like oh that's how it works like you
don't get funding unless you have a
something that's worth some cash either
a director or producer or somebody
attached right it's all about the script
and then you don't get the you know the
the distribution you can sell
international sales in front of movie
before it's even main like there's all
this stuff that you learn and you're
like oh there's a real recipe for that
mmm like when I started in fighting
there was no real recipe it was you know
Indian Reservation sell t-shirts do this
do that the road hadn't been paid but
entertainment you can actually learn it
and in in kind of conquer it if you if
you understand you know bankable stars
and you understand you know the
distribution and not every movie is
gonna be a major hit but you can get a
base hit off one and build a kind of a
you know a repertoire of things until
you really master things so I've been
real close on on finishing a couple of
projects we you know we've worked on
stuff that I'd be in and people in
scripts that I've come up with and had
other people write that kind of stuff
but it's just a passion for me yeah yeah
I could see you and um with them before
they escaped from prison a long time ago
man a constant sorrow I am
and of constant sorrow o brother where
art thou o brother where art thou Cluny
that wasn't that Olduvai Gorge claw
you're thinking a great escape with uh
with uh clint eastwood his clinics win
the Great Escape or it's the guy Paul
Newman Paul Newman no Paul Newman's in
that's another one he tries to escape
for Cool Hand Luke yeah cool that's my
point and Queen is the greatest game
yeah those are all my guys like McQueen
Paul Newman Clint Eastwood like that's
my kind of [ __ ] we know yer is a friend
of mine Oh is he
yeah Knight really really nice kid
escape from Alger okay yeah Clint
Eastwood yeah you have a film right say
you're financing a film and it's like
it's for guys it's like Shawshank
Redemption - right four guys are
escaping from prison right and they're
all former MMA fighters who's gonna be
in there you think director night guys
right now that are actually acting or
just that would be fun no it just would
be fun you think okay well Michael
Bisping is a smartass and he's actually
like back you know like yeah and he's a
talented guy he's a freakin cracker he's
funny he is and he'd be good guy to have
in there
I like probably Nick Diaz would be good
for the wild-card guy he might like you
know you might have to mess something up
even I'd be like hey we're going back
into the president people are like what
yeah the quiet guy in the van who
doesn't say anything crazy yeah yeah
he'd be a good one so we got four guys
it's two down this one you know what
let's do a Brock lesner in there he
could he could do-- he could be like the
alpha male guy and then i could pop off
or you can he can make someone wear
lipsticks and be a girl like that never
gonna get Brock in there and then maybe
a little guy he'd be a little guy
Cody Garber and he might be a guy that
they would be a good a good look he's
got the the tattoos oh that's not the
guy with the glasses that's Colby
Covington I'm thinking of right who's
the guy the coffee yeah yeah he'll put
on sunglasses sometimes our promo stuff
yeah Kobe garb right Colby
yeah no Cody Cody Garber Kody Garber
yeah and I don't wanted to be
disrespectful to him yet yeah definitely
not ever seen his pictures yeah Cody
a bad dude that's awesome I've seen some
of his fights I just the first fight I
ever saw was when Diaz fought McGregor
the second or third time whatever the
last first time you ever watched the
first number was to fight yeah and now
I've been going back and that's because
you've been champion and nose to the
grindstone yeah that's like me somebody
just I I was out here in LA
and somebody just text me are you going
to the what is it with the Dodgers in it
oh the World Series the World Series and
I said I didn't know there's a World
Series going on oh you mean the fight
each other and that's exactly and I'm
like I had no idea I really didn't I
didn't know that World Series is going
on what if there's some things you know
what's as you say that man I think about
like holidays and I sacrifice like fun
parties staying in college even like
with my friends I remember moving out to
LA before college was even done you know
constant like people's birthday parties
family members births of us you know
sibling you know nieces and nephews
bursts just things like that that I over
the years I've said yeah because I had
to stay and do comedy I had to do comedy
yeah I think I mean it's important I
mean here's here's the fine line you
know I've kept some of my friends from
like old old friends yeah 20 30 plus
years friends but you don't always get
to see them but you always have that
kinship and camaraderie and then there's
people that can come in your life that
are brand-new you can also build some
great friendships with yeah so for me
it's been like a a sit walk run bike if
somebody wants to like right now you and
I are on the same level or sitting here
and walking if I want to continue this
conversation with you and you get up and
you start walking I got to walk up next
to you and then if you start running and
I want to continue that conversation I
got to run up the side you and run on a
bike I got to get on the bike
that that idea right there it can't take
over your world but there's some level
of that and then you know hopefully you
bring your friends with you right or you
take the time or you get to a place
where you can make time to go go go beep
yeah hang out with them but be really
when there's going and you're going and
you're going like you got to be
traveling with the Wolfpack yeah you
know you have to yeah it's interesting
man it really is like in suddenly the
Wolfpack you just become like one of the
Wolves
yeah
and you don't even it's I don't know
it's kind of crazy it's like one day
somebody's an idol and the next day
they're kind of like an amigo
alright yeah it's kind of a chip you
know they're always a bit of an idol but
you know and they're always respected
but it's like yeah it's like crazy like
people that even a year ago were like
idols to me or like some of them are
like yeah it's my buddies yeah yeah that
that's I've been that way
Roy Jones jr. I used to carry Oh a Jones
jr. CD he used to have his he's around
me he was a rapper but I know his his
his DVD mm-hmm of his fights his
highlights I would carry that around
with me and I'd watch it all the time
because I watched on my computer
whatever else because I just loved the
way he fought not be covered at a party
right over the television this brings my
fight yeah I didn't mean I bring it with
me to the club right it was just a check
but no it gives you amped up yeah I'm
tough and then I become friends with him
I mean I was just before I came here I
was just with Mike Tyson we're eating
Chinese food and and wow I could meet an
MC Hammer MC Hammer was the guy's an
amazing guy ice-t Emerson amazing oh
yeah yeah it is
well he learned to Hard Knocks yes thank
about a guy that had it all and just had
to learn the hard way that you know he
had it had to be smart he's passing on
sat next him on a plane one time and we
talked the whole time yeah it was really
conversation you know what they say all
the rappers you know MC Hammer hammer
time and the pants and everything he
seems like the fun-loving rapper like
almost like a Fresh Prince kind of guy
yeah but they said out of everybody like
hammer would throw down at a drop of a
dime oh hi yeah he was like a fighter
like you don't cross the guy he'd he'd
throw down hammer time yeah you never
know and that's the way there's a lot of
fighters you would know yeah you know
who should should not mess with until
it's too late
yeah that's I get even nervous about
interviewing guys in you guys as world
cause it's like I don't even know that
much about it you know like yeah for me
it's definitely more of a perspective
like it's it's the opposite see the
thing in my life I'm always afraid to do
for myself you know so it's fascinating
that people can do it that it's part of
their just chemical makeup at some
points right I will do that yeah as a
trip as a trip let's go come on
and then we'll wrap it up man this has
been awesome and and and thank you so
much for joining us yeah I had another
one
you mentioned how your your trainer and
that Mike Brown fight he was like get
out there even though you got a broken
hand and we just saw recently in the
khabib Conor fight Duke Rufus told
Anthony Pettis not to go out for a third
round cuz he had a broken hand do you
think trainer should do you think your
trainer should have obviously one so it
worked out but I didn't win oh oh you
didn't win the Mike Brown fight oh my my
don't win the fight but uh but I it was
one way once is one of my favorite
fights Wow
looking back on because it was just
people became aware because I started
throwing elbows only and I just I lost
both hands I dislocated my thumb on this
one and I broke that one and that's like
a fight that I go back on and people
still ask me I mean that was like a long
time ago people like hey how are your
hands I'd like if I had 20 something
fights afterwards but they're fine you
know but they that's a define never
remember that absolutely there are
multiple questions you guys touched on
at first but there are multiple
questions about that from our listeners
too but do you think they're the the
corner has a responsibility do you think
they should stop it or I don't know what
what's the responsibility there it's
very individual you know and and you
know Duke Rufus is a good friend of mine
Anthony Pettis a good friend of mine and
Duke knows Anthony really really well
so they they have their own
communication style Master Tong didn't
speak alica English and I could have a
whole couple hour conversation with the
guy without speaking the same language
just by I could understand the stuff he
was saying and the points and everything
I got some great life lessons from from
the guy without us speaking the same
language which is crazy because I could
get what are you saying cetera um you
know he has a good relationship with
Anthony and I think you know when you
have a relationship like that they know
what to do mm-hmm and I know that Brian
bulls shortly after I had my experience
he he lost his world title because he
thought he broke his hand against
Dominick Cruz and didn't come out to the
thing and it's just an individual thing
I just I didn't think about it at all I
just I was like I wasn't telling him hey
I'm done with the fight I was letting
him know and he said shut up shut up you
know him
Wow champion so Dan I and I could have
won that fight I was very close to the
fifth round I had a deep choke in and I
just couldn't hold on yeah once you get
in that choke it's like a rodeo when
somebody is that is that yeah does it
obviously oh yeah my hand like we don't
brush standing we were standing I had it
like this and we hit the ground it was
like crushing my broken hand it does a
choke start to become slippery after a
while when you're like when you have it
on someone or when does that become an
element of a choke like that some
depends on the choke right there's a lot
you should you should choke you out you
want to get choked out
I definitely will we good though Paige
Vanzant to me was that John Kruse talk
did it no I'm not gonna be second sorry
aunt let you took her out
no she choked out she was on a military
tour uh-huh
and she choked out she's like okay just
tap when you're ready and put the dude
out she was with max Holloway on a tour
that's awesome I still follow her on
Instagram so just until she got married
I was like let's take a couple more than
we're gonna get out of here we're not do
this Cody call him from Michigan I got a
question for you Riya I was just
wondering what he thinks about this
[ __ ] Muppet Logan Paul thinking that
he can fight sage Northcutt I just want
to get a little bit inside see what see
what kind of [ __ ] joke this guy
should be a promoter I have him out on
the promotional too it is outrageous I'd
do that ironically and I hate to you
know cuz that guy's obviously on my side
and that sage would win the fight yeah
Logan Paul was a high-level wrestler a
lot of people don't know that he's also
a big athletic guy he's 185 pound in
high school Wow
185 pounds of my high school then he
took six in the state of Ohio which is
one of the toughest
states yeah sage on the other hand has
been fighting as a career
Logan has been doing the you know
social-media influencer thing and
everything else
the mindset man that is the most
important thing sage has it Logan has it
LO gonna be a big disadvantage obviously
and the stand up and everything else but
they always want to see sage go against
wrestlers because he's not from a
wrestling background they think that's
his weakness etc and Logan Paul has been
boxing for fun against other social
media guys and everything else but he
believes in himself and I actually know
Logan Paul and I text him after his
fight and then I text him with him and
say start talking crap to each other and
I think it could happen yeah I think it
happening I don't think it'll happen in
the UFC mm-hmm sage is now a free agent
but but unless Logan doesn't want to
fight him but I think he I think he
believes in himself I mean right he
comes off as a guy that believes in
himself right you know he told me I'm a
skull crusher Dana said he would he'd be
you know he should be put in jail if he
lets Logan Paul fight in the UFC yeah I
told Logan that lug was like I'm a skull
crusher dangerous know what he's talking
about so he really believes he might
earn it he believes himself he's only 23
Sage's 21 I was 23 24 when I started
training for fighting with just a
wrestling background just wrestling yeah
and who are we if we knock somebody that
believes in themself yeah you know so I
mean I I know that he has a lot of
haters and I appreciate this guy
honoring the fact that UFC is real and
it is real and it's it's a very
difficult thing to get to but the fact
that he's got 17 million followers and
he really believes himself and he's
willing to put it out there that's brave
if he really is willing to be put it out
there because there's one thing to say
it there's nothing to actually step in
the ring with a sage Northcutt and say
all right let's let's throw fisticuffs
but I think you could happen and what do
you think the odds would be like what
odds with it like what you know what
would Vega said well the Vegas odds
would start highly in sages favor Logan
Paul would talk himself up and he has 17
million followers and odds are are some
are proceeding all the time depending on
who's betting what money so he might be
the favorite at the end of it if he has
enough people who's gonna win you could
have you could be the ones that promote
that and I feel like yeah well we've
been talking a little bit but
you go I mean but nice to talk about
everyone in the in the picture I think
getting Logan actually want to fight
right saying you want two fights one
thing actually doing it's another but
it's all key but you know what's
interesting is that it's funny like how
having one I could see I could really
now I could see this you have one career
as a social-media influencer riding
you've had this you've kind of grown up
in this in this YouTube space and have
millions and millions of fans and now
you want to prove yourself in a
different area of your life we would all
go to a skill set we already have some
you know like if I didn't do stand-up
may be able to try to get into um you
know something else that I could you
know I would probably I would pick a
skill set that I have right and work on
that so one of his obviously good skill
sets is wrestling and I would say I
don't know Logan to this level and I'm
sure he's worked very hard to build his
following now doing whatever he's been
doing yeah pissing people off a lot of
times he's been consistent yeah growing
up and being watch yeah being a while
but I guarantee you if you asked him
what with the things he's worked on
hardest on his life have been it's
probably the most focused and dedication
has probably gone towards wrestling
because I know the wrestling world and I
know guys like that to believe in
themselves yeah and I and I and I you
know I know about a state like Ohio
which takes Russia very very serious
yeah so you know I think saging in Logan
could happen yeah Wow I'd watch it I bet
it would start out at seven to one and I
bet it would maybe break I would be bet
it could be even at some point yeah oh
no one I take a little bit dude yeah
well look but I'll tell you what and
Nick's lost a lot of money yeah but no
it's interesting you look it's
interesting because where would you go
you've already done something to it to
it height yeah you know and also he's
the the thing about the world he's in is
you have no way of defending yourself
from haters right you either like me or
I don't and there's no like well I I
mean I think that's why Logan really
enjoyed the process of having that fight
because he got to like defend himself
really because he is just a kid growing
up in a world that's really judgmental
and he's done some things
have pissed some people off but at the
end of the day he's a human being who
works really really hard who has some
talents agreed and he got to go out
there and and he does it didn't matter
what anybody thought he's gonna go punch
someone in the face and pretty admirable
yeah and it is out you know what's
amiable even if you want whether win or
lose it's admirable yeah I think what
needs to happen is that fight needs to
happen with sage and Logan and Logan I
I've mentioned this you know raising
some awareness for a charity yeah that
would be a cool thing yeah you can do it
yeah he's gonna so much power and we
could have a Theo and Delia first each
other on the same car yeah you guys glow
happily and Logan got into it before
yeah yeah and Logan got into it a while
yeah they got it uh just like a Twitter
beef or something Chris D'Elia had the
most favorited tweet ever slamming crisp
slamming Logan Paul in his response what
do you say
I'd have to Bree got to pull that out
because you know Chris Christie Lee and
I are friends from like 40 14 years ago
no yes no what was Chris deal Dyl
Delia like 14 years ago some crystally
also lost the fighter in the kids trap
to me by one percent of votes but this
was absolute one of the best things ever
I don't know what Chris D'Elia said
first but Logan Paul said I'm laughing
because I now I know why your comedy
career took a dive and hit a cadet no it
was okay that was part yeah that was
part of Chris Delia's he was like he
started off with the wrong premise and
then Chris D'Elia responded at least
when my career dies you can film it and
put it on YouTube cuz he had had that at
the Japanese thing in the forest with
the body right which I thought who cares
but but that was a great clap back by
Chris and it blew up and it blew up
because I think also people were at that
moment where they were also looking to
burn him and Chris lives in his own
universe where he likes to do his own
you know yeah it was perfect chris is
too good at that kind of stuff so yeah
but in a real fight though Chris would
be in trouble against Logan against
Logan yeah but so Chris and I go way
back because there was a TV show pitched
in 2004 about my block of houses where I
was building my team and D'Elia was
buddies with all the guys that were
doing it and they brought him along for
like as
comical piece of the director directing
thing he was part of the like the unit
it was there to film us to create a
sizzle reel to go sell and so I met
daliyah back in the day so great you
know their whole crew was just there we
had a bunch of chicks around and they
were they were trying to pick off their
own chicks at the time and everything
else and it was just a bunch of guys
that were young yeah they were trying to
do something cool that's it was before
anybody knew him I had met his father's
father as a producer yeah bill D'Elia
yeah bill D'Elia and it was billed Lia
and and some of Chris's friends that
were kind of going on a reality because
they're more you know scripted base and
they're trying to a different different
thing and we we ended up pitching a show
I didn't get taken up I think the UFC
was kind of snuffing us at the time but
but Chris and I knew each other from
that time and I've gone and watched his
career grow and yeah he's so in awesome
and he's hilarious he's very funny you
know but he had one thing that he has
more than a lot of people is he just has
extreme confidence you know yeah and it
really I think I comes from having a
great family and it you talked about not
wanting to get in a fistfight yeah you
know because hey maybe your father
figure was was you know missing or this
or this person took off whatever like
that guy comes from a very stable like
healthy mmm awesome family yeah dad and
his brothers and everyone are super cool
he's he's got like a solid foundation
that's a lot of times where the
confidence comes from yeah yeah that's
interesting man would you let your child
fight one day I'll let my kid do
whatever I want I'm not necessarily
gonna encourage it right it's not gonna
like I'm gonna like push them in that
direction it's a tough life not even I
mean everyone who wrestles like I want
my kid to wrestle because it teaches
them life skills and this and that
I think soccer yes I don't put my you
can make a ton of money make so much
money everyone sees your face yes
you know the worst that happens usually
as you do a header and hit the ball or
you fake though some of those flailing
soccer players like you could go
anywhere in the world and play soccer
and be super famous make a ton of money
yeah and and it's healthy you're running
all the time yeah you're in the Sun the
grass soccer yeah for a Cali boy to be
indoors
a cage all the time it's really I try to
do as much of my training outside his
Baha I say this yeah yeah forget about
that Oh is there anything else Nick we
had one from an old friend of Dios
okay hey Phil what's up my man have a
question for you Raya Faber you're a
huge UFC fan here
I wanted to know who would be the
perfect opponent for you to dust off the
gloves and come back and fight in the
UFC if money wasn't the issue if it was
just strictly who do you want right now
in this moment who would that fighter be
for you to get off the couch and fight
again thank you and yeah he sent this in
a while ago I cut it out but he wished
you luck before your sakuraba fight as
well oh he knew all about it that's
awesome thank you you know go back and
forth there's always a talk of the TJ
fight I mean he's the current world
champion best in the world the reason
why I fought was to be the best in the
world
you know it has to be one of the
champions right it has to be what are
the champions that I can make wait 35
sounds like a lot a big fight against
Conor Conor is my buddy but that's how
you get really paid you know that that
would have been cool
at this point I've never been like a
animosity type of fighter I'm always
like kind of trying to enjoy the process
so for me it'd be whoever is is holding
the belt at the time you want the strap
the strap and but for just joy of going
and be able to fight someone and not not
from an animosity or even for like not
even if it was a championship who's just
somebody and it could be somebody that
listicle II yeah you know I think it'd
be cool to fight a guy like khabib yeah
yeah cuz khabib 'he's
that seem just a savage beast and and i
like what he's all about he's all about
pushing the pace and and in mental
toughness and conditioning and in
willpower and that's that was my soul
always as well I I can push and push and
push and I don't mind if I get taken
down I've never been ground and pounded
and that kind of stuff so I think
that'll be fun a fun challenge cuz he's
proving himself he test
yeah and that's so and you know it's um
it's amazing that just even think of
like that part of like fighting someone
out of admiration
yeah that's exactly it and there's a lot
of guys like that that's my grappling
competition you don't know who
Sakuraba is but Sakuraba and i were
inducted in the Hall of Fame the UFC
Hall of Fame at the same time and he is
a legend of the sport like like I I had
a video like a cassette tape of him that
was like two hours long him doing all
sorts of crazy stuff you know Hawaii
Gracie is yes which Gracie's like the
founder the first got to win the the UFC
and he was at 165 pounds and he fought
Nicky they did and he was no sock rod
was known as the Gracie killer he beat
like six of them or something like wow
and submitted a bunch of the guys and so
he would do stuff like flying karate
chops and like spin around and like try
to drop his butt on someone's head and
he would like he did a special no time
limit match with a let Gracie where the
key after they had taken all that away
and he basically tried to take his pants
off and undress him during the thing and
say yeah thinking about silencing
somewhere yeah one of the Marx Brothers
he's hilarious as well yeah that pretty
wild to be inducted in the same time as
him somebody like yes that you see is it
interesting when you cuz you admire
somebody so much you look at them a
certain way and then it you can't really
feel yourself right next like on a
tandem Kenya right this seems totally
different yeah like I'm sitting there
watching this guy and he was a 185-pound
he's fighting these heavyweight killers
and like taking out legends and and
having fun doing it and then you know
I'm stopping my career and getting
acknowledged the same time he is and yet
he was one of the guys it was like you
know pump me up and then we got to
compete against each other so we just
competed in a grappling match to a draw
eight-minute draw but that was a lot of
is that the weed thing that they do with
Matt uh no okay
if I if I did the weed thing I would
probably be sleeping during that if I
were to smoke weed I would smoke a
little bit of weed laughs for a couple
minutes
eat something fall asleep all about ten
minutes right you're not a functional
guy when it comes they have an
underground thing where those guys are
like smoke in the head and roll like a
it's got felony I know that everybody
two always mentions it gets in it
awesome man I appreciate so much your
time man yeah and we got to get you on
the couch
- I'd love to come and do it where do
you guys take that we tape in Sacramento
yeah but uh have you come down there
maybe you can check out the gym maybe
make a uh maybe maybe you could do you
ever do satellite this thing satellite
or no um yeah yeah we could take it yeah
we're just gonna start taking it on the
road doing some gas like in Washington
DC this okay maybe we do something like
that you could get some of the other
fighters in the gym I've got a sage
Northcutt you could ask him about the
local Paul he's a crack-up is Inco I
mean he is the closest thing we have to
leave it to beaver on UFC but he's 190
pounds ripped and can like do a backflip
and kick you in the chin Jesus dude if
you ever if you ever if you ever see
sage and stuff it's pretty incredible
he'll do like a he like a backflip
uh-huh and land in the same spot
it's really weird yeah that's cool man
what a neat camaraderie that you story
did you get it's like a lot of it's
about the camaraderie as well like the
fighting is great but they seem like
there's a ton of camaraderie yes gyms
and different groups yes yeah it's
pretty impressive
why are you gonna watch sage his nuts so
uh yeah the camaraderie is important
because you know at the end of the day
you're beat you're doing something is
very difficult very tough no watch this
watch the slip some weird slow-motion
video but he lands at the same spot
that's kind of crazy
that's fascinating huh you talking about
zooty good energy like he can walk into
any gym he's like hey so we could be
trying to you know talk crap hey that's
a good one
like he's so funny what's up mr. Faber
hey Missy calls me mr. field he's aging
me way too fast like I got kids all over
the place now call me mr. favor really
see he's got my neighbor I had him when
he first moved to Sacramento had a
living like two houses down with all my
my good friends they had a house in the
back and my buddy Pete is just a regular
dude like successful developer guy and
it kind of took sage in and but he's
like does not want to be called mister
you know Jeremy right so he's like sage
would you please stop calling me mr.
Jeremy and he's like I mean it's sage is
like yeah okay
no problem mr. Pete we got mr. Pete
t-shirts we got everybody calls it mr.
Pete now it's pretty good I love that
man and that's that prized cul-de-sac
with you guys that you have your it's
kind of a whole squad yeah we had that
before that was that's how the team
started right um you know since moved on
yeah that was like fraternity living
basically we had five houses right next
to each other and and had probably over
50 fighters throughout the years that
lived in that little area
guys like chapman is in TJ Dillashaw and
Lance Palmer and the list goes on of
fighters that lived on that block yeah
that's fascinating man's pretty cool
wow man well forgive them real estate
advice here's my advice this is it my
real estate advice is this if you're
looking for an investment property you
find the worst house in the best
neighborhood and then you have to really
truly understand what it takes to to do
something on a budget because it doesn't
mean anything if you're getting up buy
something for too much or if you don't
know how to budget and fix something up
so do your research become an expert
before you do anything don't just buy a
house cuz it sounds cool also don't be a
straight afraid to finance and get into
debt you know that's how that's how make
big moves is is is not being afraid of
debt and you know guys like Theo and
myself and a lot of people I've met
you'll find a way I found a way by
buying a house when I was making seven
thousand dollars a year back before the
economy crashed and I moved in a bunch
of my buddies I started having more
success bought the house next door
bought the house next door and it ended
up creating a little real estate
portfolio and you know you also create
an alt comment on that you also create a
you're also as you're developing real
estate you're developing something
inside of yourself whenever you buy
something and you put your because it's
not you you're also putting money on the
line but you're putting your which you
think on the
you're putting yourself on the line
you're mortgaging against yourself and
the same thing happened to me a buddy
mine and I split a property it was a
friend that I really really trusted
financially a good business guy we split
a property we got in about fifteen years
ago and we still have it I sell to do
some you know landlording stuff every
now and then but um but we still have it
and we'll be able to sell it now for a
profit here you know 15 years later but
it's been but but but also in the years
since then I've gotten involved in other
projects because then friends start to
hear oh he owns something I'm I ask him
and then you're part of you just become
part of different conversations then
that's been kind of interesting right
and then and then there's two different
ways if you're gonna flip flip his
dangerous because it's constantly a cash
flow thing if you're gonna flip then you
have to really know your numbers know
the market know how long it's going to
take you know your budget which I've
messed up on plenty of times if you're
gonna flip if you're gonna buy fix
upsell if you're going to hold that's a
different story there's a lot more
leeway in that you just have to make
sure that the thing cash flows that
means if it's paying for itself or it's
making a hundred bucks that's good
because you're playing on the long haul
yeah and then commercial real estate is
all about the tenants that are in it if
there's a national tenant meeting like a
big-box store like a like a Dollar Tree
it's better than a mom-and-pop store
like a yogurt land yeah yogurt land or
something like that so that's a whole
nother animal so you just got to be
smart and educate yourself don't just
buy a house cuz it sounds cool yeah and
you'll start to meet friends who can do
other stuff like I don't know anything
about commercial real estate but now
maybe reach out to you Ryan asked me if
I had some questions you know and so
that's another thing you'll start to
learn it's like and people most of the
time want to share the advice that they
have or suggestions and that's one thing
that's um that's kind of fascinating is
how much people want to give away what
they learn yeah absolutely people take
it they say everything you know all
originality is borrowed and I talked
about this in my book you know a lot of
times people will like love talking
about their knowledge it's it's kind of
like a an honor to to say yeah I know
something I'd like to tell you about it
so don't be afraid to ask
don't be afraid to tell yeah awesome and
sage advice sage Northcutt Uriah Faber I
think we covered everything thank you so
much for being here man you got it
brother thanks for having a big fan yeah
I mean look dude I'll come up to sack
bro I'll be there yeah I'll be there
probably in the spring okay we'll get
you working out too and you you you do
uh
shows out there yeah you let me know
we'll bring the whole gym out man Wow
oh we got a bunch of influencers on that
team who loved it whenever whenever we
have Craig Robinson or yeah Rogan or
anybody that comes up will always go
support dude that's awesome man I want
to get choked out by somebody too yeah
that'd be cool maybe have a girl do that
to you come on bro yeah if she's cute
yeah exactly
actually yeah maybe not that cute yeah
okay all right we got a little bit
everything
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself all my
[Music]